over a hundred million people worldwide
tune in to the Super Bowl a 30-second ad
costs five million dollars it's the
biggest a day of the year and it's gone
digital but what does this digital
landscape really look like we're about
to go behind the scenes at one of the
most innovative digital marketing ad
agencies in the world Drogo five listen
in as four top digital marketers share
their thinking on socially driven
advertising and discuss how a massive
Superbowl campaign gets executed in the
new world of content where screens big
and small communicate with each other
seamlessly it's the biggest stage it's
the highest stakes it's the biggest
investment it's also the biggest
challenge and the biggest risk but I
think that's where the fun is
any brands or company would be remiss if
they didn't do other things in tandem
with a Superbowl commercial to create a
more cohesive 360 campaign it means that
you're having a cohesive approach in two
different media that will make sense and
together will make your campaign and the
message stronger something that takes
into consideration different stages of
the customer journey and different
platforms were able to talk to them I
suppose they're increasingly looking for
engagement and people talking about and
voting on it and the 30-second spot in
and of itself is really a thing of the
when it comes to integrating a campaign
it's just knowing your brand purpose
understanding your brand purpose and how
that should play out in different
channels the 30-second spot is how you
get people to notice you but it's where
they talk about it
is where you can actually have a lot of
fun do a lot of experimentation gather
data in different ways and use it to
your advantage
because it's not just about the five
million dollars for the spot anymore
it's everything you do around it to
create the 365th thing I think that's
always the tension with social is to try
and create something that's genuinely
innovative and new and kind of pushing
the boundaries but also doing it away
that's kind of accessible to a large
audience as well you know there are a
number of social platforms that are all
trying to take a little slice I'm real
excited to see how some of these brands
will utilize some of the digital tools
the utilities we have out there like
snapchat with the branded live stories
that I think will be huge for a few
brands this year live-streaming
with periscope and YouTube and it's
going to be interesting see if Browns
utilize that in a good way
and the same thing with 360 video we'll
have people using moments from show
branded filters Facebook themselves have
just released Facebook Stadium Twitter
obviously and so you can see a real move
to this kind of real-time capturing and
sharing and it's no longer quite so
cutting edge it's a little bit more
mainstream and brands therefore are able
to get involved
during the game there's a huge amount of
social mentions going on about the game
itself about brands and also about your
brand you need to identify the
opportunities you might need to identify
what's going right what's going wrong
and make sure that you're adapting that
play to essentially win an event will
generate a massive amount of data in
terms of the views and the engagement
that it generates around the event
itself and so it's going to be really
important for brands to really dig into
that and the challenge is to take that
information and generate genuine
insights and then you can take those
insights to work out what do you want to
do next data is important so long as you
know how to manipulate it and use it to
your advantage that data is just data
without some sort of lens through which
to look at it the amount of data that
we're able to get access to in real time
based from user reactions to
instantaneous view counts the number of
shares is kind of unprecedented and I
guess the challenge then is and what do
you do with all that information now can
you get your head around it how can you
make it into some of actual insights
that can help you further the brand the
rise of digital media has dramatically
changed the way brands advertise with
multiple platforms to engage audiences
mountains of data to process events like
the Super Bowl are pushing more than
just the boundaries of advertising
they're overwhelming the very device
very